where does Estrella get most of its
electricity from I really think like
winter vibes or something so wind water
power I think you have one nuclear power
plant I don't think we have family yet
ah drones and you know co-co-co Mexico
it's cold non renewable sources such as
coal
what about having nuclear in Australia
would you want that or not I don't think
I would be supportive I'm more for like
solar and wind power I would not want it
I would like to see other cleaner
technologies shared such as wind power
green energy solar power I mean I don't
really know everything about it but it
can be pretty dangerous if it does get
damaged so I don't know I think there's
better options from my point of view we
have actually many nuclear power plants
in Japan right so it's it's almost like
normal now so I can't say anything but
yeah showing people my field oh my god
ants it the population as a whole like
we don't know much about it but I think
mass publicity is very negative about it
because of the mistakes that's debatable
it is we decide to the debate with Eve
yeah well it's kind of hard to say
because it does like what generates
energy and what not with not using the
coal which is running out and there's
different like they're making more
efficient ways to get rid of the waste
although it there's still like some ways
but then again if you do have a meltdown
or something along those lines and it
can be really harmful to poor nuclear
energy as long as it's away from
populations where they sort of stuff
can't happen I mean we have a lot of
like spare land so if we stuck it out in
the desert somewhere I would think that
it would affect too many people would
you want nuclear power in Australia oh
good yes yes yes
tell me one it's clean apart from the
waste but I'm sure we'll figure
something out with that well what about
the potential of something like what's
happening in Japan that the main one
that they're worried about there was an
old reactor was supposed to go out of
commission very shortly
they couldn't have foreseen and I
a natural disaster coming I think it was
a bit of a fluke accident and I think
every year they're developing these
nuclear power plants more and more we're
getting a better understanding of it and
I think it's a very safe viable way of
generating power well yeah I think it's
probably the cleanest alternative we've
got at the moment as you know like coal
releases a lot of stuff into the
atmosphere and I think it would be very
naive to think that doesn't have an
effect also if you're using something
like wind power something like you have
to clear a lot of land to make it viable
because it's not really that efficient
so I think you're really nuclear is our
only option for mass production of power
and considering we have a growing
population it's the only option we've
really got